[Music]
i will create the next prom king you
make it sound so easy you don't think i
can do it
it's definitely a really good take on
the original there are so many
similarities but it's also like a huge
difference
all right let's go inside addison takes
on the freddie prinz jr role in this
reimagining of the hit 1999 movie she's
all that
the full trailer drops on addison's tick
tock tomorrow and fans will get a
glimpse of kourtney kardashian in her
very first movie role what was it like
to work with her in this capacity it was
completely different than obviously
anything she's ever done before
she said she was super nervous but i
think she did great it was funny seeing
her
kind of channel something different
who's the new guy a little scruffy but
cute
the new guy addison's character
transforms is played by cobra kai's
tanner buchanan
and he's not a big social media guy so
he had no idea who addison was before
meeting her on set
he is a total disaster weird anti-social
what was it like to wear
extensions uh kudos to all
girls or anybody that wears extensions
because they
hurt they hurt a lot i had that hair
when i was like
16 or 17 years old they actually put the
extensions in and i looked at myself and
i was like
oh god no please help me i can't go back
to this right now
rachel lee cook is returning in this
movie streaming august 27th on netflix
but she's playing a new character what
was it like to have
her play your mom yeah that was really
fun i think we had a really good
on-screen connection
it's only a mistake if you don't learn
from it honestly the messages of that
movie did really need
updating so i'm really excited for
people to see this version so i was a
bet you can all go to hell